good morning believe nation today's
messages recognize opportunity over to
you Earl Nightingale there's nothing
more pitiful to my mind that the person
who wastes his life running from one
thing to another forever looking for the
pot of gold at the end of the rainbow
and never staying with one thing long
enough to find it no matter what your
goal may be perhaps the road to it can
be found in the very thing in which
you're now engaged you see the average
man believes some businesses are better
than others instead of realizing the
truth that there are no bad businesses
there are just those people who don't
know enough to see the opportunities and
the work they're in no matter what our
work happens to be it's our business
we're the manager if there seems to be
no future or opportunity in it it isn't
always because it's not there but
perhaps only because we can't see it I
get a lot of entrepreneurs who ask me
what's the best business to start and it
blows my mind because there is no one
single best business to start the best
business to start is the one that you
feel passionate about the one that you
see a vision for something that nobody
else sees the one where you have some
pain that nobody else is solved yet and
you're passionate about solving it it's
not about what ink magazine says is the
five hottest trends for next year and
trying to jump on that because too many
people do that right say oh you know
biotechnology is growing so I'm gonna
get into that even though you have no
idea about biotechnology and so that's
the fastest way to lose money right
Forex is taking off so I'm gonna jump
into Forex or I can make tons of money
from home with this easy amazing online
opportunity and you jump in there and
you lose all your money you have to do
the thing that you love and that you see
the opportunity in I think entrepreneurs
we're good at seeing the opportunity in
almost anything right we're optimistic
we're positive I walk into any business
and I think about how it could be better
and I think it's good to train yourself
to do that I walk you know in this mall
here we've got a cop
shop we've got a liquor store we've got
an office supply store and whenever I
walk in I think of if I were running
this business I would do this this and
this this and this and there's always
opportunities and the flip side of that
is you could bring some opportunities
from other markets and other industries
to apply it to your business Howard
Schultz started Starbucks because he was
in Mullane in Italy and saw all these
people hanging out in coffee shops and
he looked to the North American market
and thought he saw Dunkin Donuts inside
you know nobody's hanging around the
coffee shops we're in Italy it's the
center of their culture and thought I
could bring this to North America I want
to create that community and family vibe
and that was a foundation of Starbucks
which became a global brand and so by
looking at what other businesses are
doing you can bring opportunity to your
company as well and so I learned from
other businesses I learned from baseball
teams I learned from league of legends I
learned from music superstars you know
that I learned from the top ten series
and ian's presto series you can find how
these people think and how they're
solving different problems and apply
that to what you're facing in your life
today to find an opportunity to help you
become the best version of yourself
so the question of the day today is I'm
curious to find out what opportunity
you've recognized from another industry
and applied it to your business to have
a big impact I'm really curious
leave it in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
nespresso TV go